interviews da du wenn ich spieler tag 1
alles klar stellen ja hallo mein name
ist vanessa und ich spiele seit ungefähr
drei jahren starten werde ich weiß nicht
warum ich hier bin
man kann es darum valley auf dem
smartphone ganz normal erste mal in
berlin
hallo leute ich es wieder einmal waren
und willkommen zu einer neuen folge wie
schmeckt und heute machen wir essen aus
dem einsatz beliebten spiels tardelli
positives in positive energie ins
universum schickst konnten star willie
placement zurück ja ist da denn das ist
das dorf und meinhof steht die habe ich
vor paar jahren von dem großvater geerbt
und das war jetzt natürlich erst mal ein
schock
also so ein hof zu erben da muss man
sich auch erst mal entscheiden
stadtleben land leben das war ja auch
nicht gewohnt und dann kam auch der
bürgermeister gleich wo es hierüber hat
mich begrüßt dass man hier auch
superklasse ja und dann ging das
eigentlich auch schon los war lag
überall holz gras steine und ich erst
mal mit meinem schlechten werkzeugen er
musste das alles klein hacken und
einsammeln
aber ich habe das material auch gut
gebraucht weil man kann mit dem material
alles baut man muss nur wissen wie und
man braucht das material also angefangen
langsam mit den ersten feldern dann
macht man sich ein bisschen platz und
dann muss man zu kia gehen ein paar
samen kaufen also gut am anfang hat man
pastinaken samen kam und wie kriegt man
gleich die kann man da gleich einlassen
aber dann muss man natürlich immer
größer denken also zu bier im supermarkt
erstmal neue kaufen wenn man sich dann
fleißig in seinfeld gekümmert hat kann
man auch relativ schnell ernten und geld
machen ja schwierige situation also ich
muss ihnen sagen die mähne
das ist wirklich ein stück arbeiter
trauen sich auch nicht alle rein also
dafür muss man hart gewappnet sein denn
die monster die einen in der mine
erwarten die haben es in sich
natürlich kann man da auch viel finden
kupfer silber gold diamanten sogar ab
und zu habe ich sogar diamanten gefunden
also das leben aber die monster
drei minister ich habe dinge in dieser
mine gesehen die sich nicht nur in ihrem
schlimmsten träumen aus träumen könnten
gehen sie niemals in dieser mine rein ja
auch mein haus das ist toll
also das kann ich mir von robin komplett
ausbauen lassen am anfang war es noch
relativ klein das muss ich sagen
aber als ich meine küche eingebaut habe
als semiprofessioneller gemüsebauer
anlagen in arbeiter- und viehzüchter da
sammelt sich einiges an zutaten an und
mit den koche ich wirklich gerne
ich hab da auch so ein paar
lieblingsgerichte zum trinken mag ich
eigentlich ganz gerne den cranberry
candy linker das gericht aus einem spiel
sind werden alle zutatenlisten nicht
allzu lang sein und für den trainer
barry candy brauchen wir cranberries und
ich dachte eher an frische cranberries
da wir die aber nicht im supermarkt
hatten
getrocknete warme snacks mal irgendwann
wieder anfuhr weil ihr kann kein zufall
sein dann brauchen wir noch einen roten
apfel und zucker und damit wir nicht
auch trockner süßer pampe herumkauen
müssen habe ich noch mineralwasser dazu
genommen weil ich weiß jetzt die frage
ich habe die zutaten gekauft aber ich
habe mir nicht vorgestellt wie man es
macht ok schön und dann ab und möchte
diese schilder oder auch nicht gewaschen
weil er immer viel rausgenommen
[Musik]
wir müssen unseren apfel meisten
moscheen aufnahme machen wir da müssen
so so dem tee und wenn es gut ist habe
ich in den neuen zivilisation für
komplexe ball an eine lehrerin die hat
mal ganz demonstrativ diesen mittleren
teil vom apfel gegessen
ich bin mein eigener biomüll in unsere
mixa ich meine dafür dass sie getrocknet
sind sehen die noch relativ frisch aus
so saß ich habe mal ein bisschen wasser
rein gemacht und wie habe ich viel
zucker sollen jetzt mit dem zucker alles
verloren auf dem glas nimmt man das da
auf dem fall noch ein paar quellen
berichten boden liegen
bild diabetiker ein platz eins dürfe
jeder guter cocktail wir wissen braucht
eiswürfel wir machen kein cocktail aber
trotzdem cool auf mit dem zweifel gegen
den schützen
wenn man jetzt trinken würde hätte man
mineralwasser nach passiert da nicht mal
so scheiße aus und wünschten wir uns
wieder der allerwichtigsten frage wie
schmeckt der cranberry kann die aussage
berlin
mein gott tun er ist so lecker ist so
die cranberry kenny gibt 125 energie und
56 heilung und wandern möchte dann kann
man ihn sogar verkaufen für 125 gold
antrag auf der farm gehabt wir standen
gütesiegel klasse a 4,6 sterne auf
google
wenn google kommen wir zu unserer
vorspeisen kika moderator it in some
stark unsere vorspeise nennt sich kohli
flowers also blumenkohl käse nach das
habe ich bei cam bekommen das rezept
nachdem ich bei ihr drei herzen erreicht
hat das gibt 138 energie und 62 heil
ungarisch lag 300 gold kriegt man dafür
wenn man es verkaufen möchte dafür
brauchen wir
blumenkohl oder blumen wurden als zweite
und letzte zutat brauchen wir käse mit
ein paar löchern drin also der käse
weist dadurch verdi hat löcher so und
wird zu
wir entfernen das grüne von unserem
klinikum gebens unserem haar
der hunger das muss hier entfernt werden
unsere reichhaltige vorspeise aber ich
bin schon ziemlich gespannt wie es
schmeckt ich kann mir zwar schon ist es
richtig hammer wird es auf jeden fall
kliniken zu tragen so sollte das dann
aussehen noch mal so sollte danach alles
aussehen mag nummer so sollte denn hier
ankommen so selektiert libi heißt es
wenn man den fisch so viele
wir brauchen unseren reiskocher aber
nette was brauchst du denn für
blumenkohl gute frage alles ist schwul
und dann sachen aufzuholen
also ein reiskocher ist vielseitig
einsetzen diesen aufsatz packe ich jetzt
größten fünf minuten oder sondern damit
die nur so vor
dann haben das jetzt hier so drauf sind
wie darauf die polen wissen was gemeint
hast decke drauf einstellen es jetzt
hier kochen und dann wird das 25 minuten
gehts dampfgaren vor jetzt werden wir
unserem symbol warten können wir schon
mal den chips vorbehalten
wir probieren wir erstmal was wir uns
hier gegönnt haben wird sich aber denn
eigentlich so eine reise räume ich muss
die reifen drehen
daher wird auf 1100 blog da schon gut
[Musik]
gebraucht wird mit keira kannst du eh
nichts falsch machen
training on the job oder schon ort
berichten aber wenn ich mir vorstelle
von flughäfen für mich es ist schon
richtig krank überbacken
der blog ist eine vorspeise nötig in der
lage unsere kräuter sind jetzt vorgegart
kommen sie in unserer offenen schale
da wissen wir jetzt unseren käse drauf
und nicht verlegen habe ja viel gemacht
und bisschen so bringst du auch kinder
zum gemüse essen ist gesund
cornflakes alternative party
ich gehe auf jeden fall danach mal zum
yoga kein joghurt marathon zu trainieren
ja man kann sagen was wird ist sieht
verdammt gut aus die party kommt jetzt
in den ofen ein paar sekunden später ja
polizei ist fertig mein gott warum sind
wir noch nie auf die idee kommt dass zu
machen und es lief fantastisch so
neuwirth ist so lecker da kommt schon
eine vorspeise dankeschön frau das denn
die in käse dann stellen wir uns
natürlich mal wieder der
allerwichtigsten frage wie schmeckt
blumenkohl käse aussagen berlin kochen
immer so einfach
es ist so lecker
es ist so lecker dass man sich den mund
verbrennen weil man zumindest also man
hat nie das gefühl dass man nur nudeln
käse ist schmeckt so knackig und durch
den käse sind würzig 15 15
ja ich würde es eine acht geben dass
geführt kommen wir zum hauptgang für
unseren hauptgang brauchen wir nur vier
zutaten und zwar machen wir die
fischtage der fisch takko also damit hat
sich nämlich möglich selber übertroffen
aber man muss sieben herzen bei ihm
erreichen um überhaupt das rezept von
ihm zu kriegen dieses gericht lohnt sich
aber wirklich weil man +2 beim fischen
bekommt 165 energie und 74 heilung
kommen und wenn man es verkaufen will
500 gold also das ist super rezept wir
brauchen mit thunfisch pott hier und da
brauchen wir noch
mayonnaise und rotkohl also man muss
aber sagen dass das bild und die zutaten
einfach nicht übereinstimmt denn man hat
rotkohl und dem film und auf dem bild
kann man ganz genau sehen dass da so
fisch und darunter etwas grünes ist
deswegen weiß ich jetzt nicht gehalten
uns eher an die zutaten als an das bild
oder ja ja wir können nichts grünes herz
aber ich habe nur ein kleines stück
thunfisch gekauft haben
q1 des tun für nicht lecker mein plan
ist es wir beraten im thunfisch machen
aus den tod ihres tacos mission den
gekochten thunfisch mit mario und zu so
einem ofen haben so 1 5 mio
links marco gefangen an in denen bier
denn nicht nur raten also ich fand das
heißt unser thunfisch steak ja in der
zeit in der unser fisch inspiriert
machen wir mal unsere rotkohl forum ist
cool so hart wenn man den fisch und
verstand wieder nicht ausüben stück
fleisch und fisch ok brauchen wir ja nur
ein bisschen
bei kleinfischen hier konnte man cool
schneidet wichtig wie so ein koch holz
sowie beim dönermann haben wir kümmern
uns selbst um die tobias in den zutaten
steht das verwendet werden
aber wir müssen wir jetzt wie so eine
takko formen krieg ich dachte dass wir
sie einfach auch skipper im roten machen
und dann herunter hängen das zum sonntag
wollen sich eigentlich nur zwei
versuche es mal so so und nun gucken wir
mal was unsere pflicht geworden ist ist
besser jeder koch der welt tötet mir ja
das gute aus das darf so sein gutes
treppchen wolke kurzem ihr drittes oder
das mai und dann haben wir auch
eigentlich superfroh salz und pfeffer
kümmel benutzen ja ja dann brauchen wir
eine charlie dieser schale mixen jetzt
alles zusammen ist mir der thunfisch und
dann so vielen guten krimis ordentlich
rein wer es nicht auf jeden fall schon
mal das ist gut so oder nach mehr
einfluss computertechnik zuviel verrückt
was es alles gibt hinterlassen habe und
gerade hier ist dann wichtig wenn er
abkühlt dass ich ihn so halte weißt du
ja kommt ist ein tango ja so ich mache
jetzt ein bisschen salz rhein-main salz
gips bei star werde jetzt nicht wirklich
okay nächsten trick wie man das am
besten da reinkommt jetzt stellt sich
die frage ist das ist gesund beginnt
sofort immer sagen ich bin auch ein
bisschen kritisch dem rotkohl gegenüber
bild.de kleist ein blogger fuß da bin
ich gespannt wie viel schmerz kann ich
würde den zweiten gang kriegen also den
hauptgang ja genau das war der fischfang
auf dem bild war in grün also ich habe
gelesen dass der rotkohl drin ist kann
ja gar nicht sein als ein fehler okay
weder wenn gemacht oder kommt da schon
danke und sieht doch gut aus so 2 jan
fischer co nach star willie aa und nun
stellen wir uns wieder der aller aller
aller wichtigste frage wie schmeckt der
fisch pakistan berlin
ich bin so gespannt ich habe gar keiner
wissen wir auch nicht so sondern hat
noch nie gegessen
erstmals lag ich finde aber den rotkohl
muss man ihn in die freiheit schney
nicht zu dicke stücke von rot grün
zwischen malsch mc.de super zusammen
aber du hast recht ein bisschen zitrone
drauf sondern müssen zitrone drauf
machen nicht nur spenden ist das meine
damen und herren ist lecker ja jetzt
habe ich wieder lust bekommen auf
nachtisch die nachspeise ist ein
bisschen unkonventioneller als man sie
erwarten würde
und wenn man einen kleinen durchhänger
hatte noch länger arbeiten muss probiert
man die glasierten süßkartoffeln die
haben nämlich 200 energie und 90 heilung
holla die waldfee das rezept bekommt man
im ersten jahr am 21
tag im herbst bei die königin der saucen
einfach einschalten und fernsehen ich
weiß nicht warum man das gericht
verkaufen sollte aber ihr könnt es
machen für 200 gold- und unsere zutaten
sind wieder rechts und wir brauchen eine
süßkartoffel und ca nbc die zubereitung
ist auch wieder relativ simpel erst
schälen wir unsere süßkartoffel das bin
ich von außen sorgten wenn man dann die
schale ab macht jetzt schneiden wir die
süßkartoffel sie verstehen wir schneiden
sie in scheiben auf dem bild sieht man
ja dass es scheiben sind deswegen
mich für schreiben entschieden und hätte
auch promis machen können aber nein es
ist ja ein bisher dann legen wir sie
auch aufhören würde praktisch ja der
zweite und letzte schritt ist zucker
drauf machen dann versuchen wir
verschiedene varianten weniger mitleid
der menschen richten ist vorgewärmt so
und diesmal in berlin kommen jetzt in
den ofen
ich liebe backen eine ewigkeit später
sind wir eine richtig gute caravan
schicht kriegen wenn wir sagen passt
eigentlich nicht
der glücksfall das ist für brown damals
muss mein ok view in der menge wenn sie
doch gehüllt sind durch gleichheit und
nun stehe man zum allerletzten mal die
allerwichtigste frage wie schmeckt das
sehr aussage valley
ok dann wollen wir mal gucken wie unser
dass er so schmeckt man kann's essen das
ist nicht eklig aber irgendwie nicht
geil ich bin dieser christopher stein
aber gucken wie geil dieses kicker darum
darauf ist weil ich jetzt nicht so dass
herr weil es gerade vielleicht ist auch
nicht bremst eine beilage man weiß also
von den dreien ist das schwächste
gericht macht es nicht nach leute das
war's mit dem video wenn es euch
gefallen hat dann lass mir doch bitte
einen daumen nach oben da und abonniert
main kanal fertig gemacht habt dann
verpasst ihr kein neues video und ich
bedanke mich ganz herzlich an google
play für diese kooperation
ihr findet das spiel und die infos alle
in der infobox also einmal runterschauen
da könnt ihr alle links finden und dann
würde ich sagen
[Musik]
diese wird mit sohn und ich hab mir
jetzt erstmal star duo valley für acht
euro 99 auf mein smartphone
heruntergeladen toll dann kann ich mir
jetzt gleich meinen nächsten ruf machen
muss jetzt nur noch den namen und den
hof nahmen
[Musik]
entschuldigen sie bitte können sie mir
sagen wie spät es ist
ich muss